[Music]
s thank you for joining us on spectator
TV um you're in Northern Israel at the
moment only 12 kilometers from the
border with Lebanon uh currently there
are lots of attacks going there uh from
from Hezbollah with Israel responding in
turn can you describe what the situation
is like up there at the moment
I can tell you that tonight we hardly
slept we heard the
fightings the it was difficult to
explain to my little girl this is from a
personal point of view to describe it
it's kind of a low-scale war I'll put it
maybe this way a limited War because H
since H the war started up north there
are daily attacks that are coming from
Lebanon either anti-tanks you vs mortars
missiles infiltration you name it h
While most of the attacks are anti-tanks
and mortars and most of these or
actually all of these are coming
fromb some infiltrations were carried
out by Islamic Jihad and some missiles
were launched by Hamas as well but the
leading player against the state of
Israel from the Israel Lebanese border
is we also had a few launching of
missile from Syria three times until now
and what is actually happening that very
quickly IDF understood that it needs to
be dealt and every H Squad of kisb that
reaches to the area of the border and
tries to launch whatever it is whether
it's anti-tm mortars or sometimes they
even try to Target our uavs with with
the
uh is surface to air missiles all of
these are dealt by the IDF and the IDF
is destroying this H squads and killing
kis operatives so in many in many places
when when I hear the national media it
is reported as exchange of fire but I
don't expect I don't accept this framing
since I think it's not exactly exchange
of fire there is no interest for the IDF
to exchange fire with
and there is no interest for the idea of
to open another front but this second
front is already active from day one
against us and that's why eventually it
needs to be dealt as for the civilian
part 60,000 Israelis were evacuated from
the communities next to the Border 0 to
5 kilometers I myself live about 9
kilometers from the B so me and my
family were not evacuated but the
feeling here is as I've said is a
feeling of a low scale or limited War
because it's not
quiet it's not a border of peace and
quietness and I don't live anymore in
the the peaceful community I used to
live because there are soldiers
everywhere and it is clear to us that
the IDF is prepared for something much
greater than maybe kbal is planning I
was going to say so um Hassan nazala the
General Secretary of Hezbollah is due to
speak tomorrow do you get the sense I
mean obviously we're talking ahead of
that we can't ignore exactly what he's
going to say but can you maybe just talk
us through about what hezb are thinking
do you think they they have an incentive
to expand this into a into a fullscale
war war rather than rather than fire and
probing at the
moment so first I agree that we don't
know what he's going to say tomorrow and
I would say even more than that H maybe
even tomorrow he will not give us all
the assets that everybody in the world
is like kind of waiting for what n we
say okay and it may may leave us with
the question marks but what we see
clearly is that Iran is pushing his
proxies H to become part of this
campaign because this was the plan right
from the beginning and here which brings
me to another point this is not a war
between Israel and Hamas this is very
misleading Hamas didn't initiate all of
that by itself this is a war between
Iran and the Western values and Iran in
the past decade built its capabilities
to create a multi front campaign against
the state of Israel from various fronts
meaning Yemen which is already active h
Gaza West Bank Lebanon Syria even Iraq
and maybe even inside Israel this is
what they want okay the capabilities
exist in most of these
places excellent example the fire power
ofal is 10 times more than the fire
power of
Kamas and until this moment you know we
don't see any um messages that are
coming out either from Iran or fromis
that are saying okay we want to calm
down maybe we should stop we don't see
all of that the the propaganda that goes
out ofis is a propaganda that support
the expansion of the war that support
they published today giving you two
examples published today a video that
support Yemen under the flag all of us
is Yemen as if Israel attacked Yemen or
whatever you know we are not we have no
business with that but we were attacked
already four times by drones and
missiles from
Yemen uh and another video that was
published at the beginning of this week
H by the propaganda of kisala
emphasizing the capabilities of kisala
to carry out exactly what Hamas has
already executed on October 7th while
the whole message of this video is that
hisbah Warriors are willing to die for
the cause which is getting to Jerusalem
and killing Israelis that's kind of the
botom line of three minutes video say if
if the war does expand and Hezbollah
launch a fullscale Invasion or Warfare
how prepared do you think Israel is to
fight a war on two
fronts it's quite a challenge of course
H definitely when we speak of ground
forces that's why I think that the IDF
is aware of what is happening up north
and the fact that you know I'm saying
that as a resident of the galy we can no
longer live with this monster that you
know just end the war and one day when
they will decide they will Massacre us
the same way they did the in in the area
of Gaza Israel must be prepared to deal
with
the challenge as it is from the north as
well as I've said it's yes it's a
challenge of ground invasion of hisbah
Commando Fighters and it's a challenge
of the missiles and the drones some of
them are accurate in the hands of kis
200,000 different kind of of missiles
and drones um I think what the IDF is
now doing is prioritizing saying okay we
must H push forward in Gaza
there is no way Hamas will be able to
survive this this is something that is
unheard of and unacceptable and we must
get rid of the monster over there and
afterwards we'll see what could be done
and in which way it could be could be
done up North but again I want to remind
everybody that meanwhile there are
60,000 Israelis that cannot go cannot go
go back to their homes up north here
because of the threat of the anti-tanks
I see um we should turn for a little bit
to the situation in Gaza uh it's been
reported this morning that Israeli
troops have reached the edge of Gaza
City is the perception in Israel that
the the southern campaign is doing well
that it's sort of meeting its targets at
taking on
Hamas yes I think the the impression is
that it is doing well I think there is a
consensus and we Israelis we usually
disagree upon everything but here there
is a consern to someon Israel is that
after what happened H there is no way
that Hamas would stay and we must do
whatever we can to eliminate the
threat H it's you know I always compare
it to what happened in World War II like
H did anybody even imagine a scenario
that after all what the Nazis are done
they will be able to stay on power or
that Hitler will stay on power it was
clear to everybody that this enemy
should be fought until its defeat and
this is what is clear today is to the
Israelis and I hope that eventually it
will be clear to the war world because
Hamas atrocities as I've
said we were near them we were meters
away from them but actually the hatred
is not against Israelis and Jews Alone
by the way Arabs were killed byas as
well H this hatred is also against
everything the West
represent H you know I see uh support to
Hamas coming from lgbtq or queers uh
coming from people that believe in
democracy and in Freedom in various ways
Hamas is not part of what you believe
in completely not and if these people
will go to visit Gaza or as an act of
solidarity they will get killed by
Hamas yeah so Sor there seems to be sort
of a discordancy almost which is that
Israel seems very focused seems very
United on its on the necessity of
tackling Hamas yet in the wider West now
there seems to be a sort of wavering of
support support for Israel's campaign uh
so yesterday we had President Joe Biden
say he supported a humanitarian Paws I
mean what did you make of his
comments look I totally understand the
need to to meet the needs of the of the
gazans with regard to humanitarian need
but I think that eventually and it is
also due to international law we must H
meet the humanitarian needs of the
hostages as well so okay if if
humanitarian Aid is getting into Gaza
the r the Red Cross should be able to
meet our hostages in in that are in the
hands of Kamas I think this is something
that makes sense it's
humanitarian it's it's about humans life
and I don't understand why these two
demands are not going hand in
hand do you think though in terms of do
you think do you get the sense that
Western support is going to waver though
now I mean we're going to see this more
and more with when Israel Israel's
bombing campaign does have a high
civilian toll in Gaza do you think we're
going to see the West sort of shy away
from supporting Israel more and more
it's becoming more difficult for Israel
we already see that unfortunately and I
I must say something around that you
mentioned the amount of casualties in
Gaza which everybody is sorry for that
okay again we have no business in
killing and gazans because it doesn't
serve before morality okay it doesn't
serve our interests if we want to defeat
Hamas we want to kill as less gazans as
possible we understand that the the way
to defeat Kamas goes through as less
casualties as possible we we all
understand that okay but what Hamas is
doing is is is using its own people as
human Shields its headquarters and
tunnels are based below the homes so
what the world should do is hel Hamas
accountable rather than hold Israel
accountable and one more thing around
that Israel is not occupying Gaza in any
way since 2005 we are not there there
was no IDE of soldiers in Gaza since
2005 except for a specific operation
that again happened due to atrocities
that were carried out by Hamas and 20
years of rockets that were launched by
Hamas and Islamic Jihad to the state of
Israel against the communities children
in Israel grew up afraid to go to the
bathroom because of the sirens people
need to address all of that so I think
that the international pressure here is
on the the wrong place
there should be an international
pressure but there should be
International pressure on Hamas itself
because he is the one who is putting his
own people at risk he's the one who is
doing that deliberately in order to
escape from a from a defeat and they
don't care about the human lives of the
gazans we call them to evacuate from the
war zones Hamas block their way with
evacuation everybody's talking about the
fuel Hamas has enough fuel it stole the
fuel of the civilians in order to
continue to fight us all of this should
be addressed and I think it's very
important to look at the full picture
while we speak about the collateral
damage and people getting killed
moreover I have you know just a little
bit of of a question here here in Israel
we had a horrified Massacre of
Israelis and it is until today almost
almost a month had passed and we don't
have the exact number of how many people
were killed Hamas is publishing numbers
every day how do they know how many
people were killed in each and every
attack how do they know that these were
all civilians the numbers that are
coming out of Gaza include the 1500
terrorists that invaded into Israel and
H slaughtered our
families the numbers that are coming out
of Gaza include the
Hamas ER terrorist that are fighting
against the IDF now nobody knows what's
the numbers exactly the distinction
between civilians and and terrorists how
they were killed nobody knows and
everybody just you know H view Israel as
responsible and I think it's important
to look at the the details in this
picture for all of us to be capable of
defeating Terror because Israel had no
interest to go to a military operation
in Gaza and we are doing that because
everything that happened we are doing
that because we cannot tolerate another
Massacre